joining us right now magnus cross and
congratulations on a fantastic ending to
the day
thank you so again in like a must-win
situation like yesterday you pull
through
you come up with something amazing so
tell us about this uh
final game uh yeah first of all it's
very very unusual to have
uh four such sort of one-sided games
uh that that we had today i will
say that i had lost
a little bit of control in in that final
game though
but i felt that i was always at least
at least pushing but clearly he missed
he missed something there that i had
this intermediate move of pushing my
phone
uh in case he had taken taken mine as
i'm sure you you went through and
after that it was it was simple
obviously
what you mean by uh one-sided games
magnus
uh not just that uh there were four
decisive games and uh both of them were
one-sided in the sense that only one
player was really
was really pushing in in any of them so
usually you have some
uh interesting games some more kg but
this
yeah this time it's very different um
magnus it seemed that
uh both players struggled with with the
black pieces how are you going to change
up your strategy to make sure you can
survive those games
tomorrow no i don't know
i do feel um
though that in the third game
yeah i mean in the first game i mixed up
something in the opening and
he just um crushed me
uh to be fair and but in in the third
game
i do feel like i had a very decent
position there from
from the opening so in that sense that
wasn't
that wasn't that bad but i do think he
played a very good game though
you mentioned uh that every game was
one-sided but the third game was there
any turning point
in that one you said the opening was
okay there
yeah the problem was that i
um i spent a lot of
time uh there
[Music]
uh when i played d5 uh and basically
i didn't spend nearly enough time
considering f4
uh when he played that somehow i was
focused on
knight f3 but then i i think i'm i'm
fine so
firstly if i was going to play d5 i
should have played it a lot quicker
and secondly i probably shouldn't have
played at all
but anyway then yeah i got to be
flustered when i
i realized that f4 was less stronger
than i thought and so i
decided i i went for this knight h4
which i hadn't really
considered much at all i just thought
um you know i wasn't satisfied with qnh4
so let's
try the other one but then yeah you may
have had a very very
uh good ending and it was hard to get
away from
well mine is you mentioned it four uh
one-sided games for
deciding games for very entertaining
games so
how are you enjoying it when when it is
like it is today
i'm not enjoying it at all
because i can't i constantly have to win
on demand
how do you manage that actually yeah
what psychology do you use
uh no the thing is um
it feels like i'm getting
i'm getting some some play at the very
least in in the
italian and i i think is as long as you
cannot
sort of neutralize your opponent's
opening then
it's it's not so it's not so easy uh so
that's that's really the reason why i've
been able to
um to win those games obviously
in the first um
in the first white game i had it was one
of those situations where
um he went bishop f5
and i knew that wasn't the right move
but i didn't know exactly
exactly why but this has been talked
about
a lot before but it's a situation when
you know that your opponent is prepared
like he he knew
and then your opponent starts thinking
then you're immediately
something in your brain tells me oh
since he's not prepared and it turned
out that
uh his move was just losing so
all right well magnus we're definitely
looking forward to another entertaining
day tomorrow thank you for joining us
and
best of luck in the second match thank
you